12h25 toulouse ce matin concorde
s'envole pour la première fois vers new
york l'avion aux couleurs d'air france
et de la british airway un kit est tout
à leur toulouse blagnac destination
l'aéroport kennedy de new york
l'avion est attendu dans le courant de
l'après midi
nos confrères américains du new york
times souligner l'événement ce matin
grâce à un éditorial qui souhaite la
bienvenue
non pas au concorde peut-on lire dans
cet éditorial mais au triomphe de
procédure juste et légale pour régler
les problèmes émotionnels posée par cet
appareil les tribunaux conclut le new
york times ont montré la voie lors de la
confrontation la courtoisie doit
maintenant prévaloir
quant au syndicat cgt de l'aérospatiale
de toulouse
il a envoyé ce matin un message à la
population de new york et dans ce
message on peut lire les milliers
d'ouvriers d'employés de techniciens
d'ingénieurs de cadres qui ont mené la
réalisation de concorde jusqu'à son
terme attendent beaucoup de son essor
commercial pour la garantie de leur
emploi concorde est parti tout à l'heure
de toulouse blagnac vers new york
porteur d'espoir pour des millions de
techniciens d'ouvriers d'ingénieurs et
de cadres
vous le savez espérons que ce que feront
les pilotes cet après midi à l'arrivée
sur new york permettra aux américains
d'accueillir avec courtoisie notre
appareil franco brit air l'actualité est
bien c'est d'abord pour chacun d'entre
nous contribuables ce qui a été décidé à
l'assemblée nationale un nouveau barème
des impôts en quoi consiste-t-il en quoi
sommes nous
directement concerné tout de suite des
précisions avec daniel duigou
c'est en effet à 5 heures du matin que
les députés se sont quittées après avoir
voté l'ensemble de la première partie du
budget c'est-à-dire les recettes pas de
grands changements
excepté l'abattement de 10% sur le
revenu imposable des pensionnés et des
retraités
les bénéficiaires cet amendement de la
commission des finances votée à
l'unanimité seront donc principalement
les personnes âgées pour compenser la
perte de recettes la tva sur les
locations et les crédits-bails des
voitures de tourisme sera majoré a été
adopté sans grande difficulté en effet
le nouveau barème de l'impôt sur le
revenu les dix premières tranches ont
relevé deux sets et demi pour cent les
deux dernières seulement de 6 et 5 % a
été également adoptée avec la nouvelle
vignette auto l'augmentation du prix des
carburants en deux temps le 1er février
et le 1er juin
le super passera à 2 42 et à 2,58
l'ordinaire comme vous le voyez à 2,23
et à 2,39
en revanche les députés ont rejeté la
super dit niet sur les voitures de
société enfin dernier article a signalé
l'assemblée a reconduit tenait en
l'adoucissant la taxe sur le train de
vie bateau actions de sociétés de chasse
etc
la taxe ne s'appelle plus taxes
exceptionnelles et elles exigent non
plus 3 mais maintenant quatre éléments
voilà vous êtes fixé ça allait bien
voyons maintenant avec michel denisot
l'ensemble des informations qui
continuent de nous parvenir et peut-être
revenons aussi sur un certain nombre de
faits de la journée d'hier concernant ce
qui s'est passé à mogadiscio lyon ne
connais pas encore les résultats de l
autopsie d'andreas baader et de ses
disciples qui se sont suicidés hier
matin dans leur cellule de la prison de
stuttgart c'est le top six ont été
réalisés la nuit dernière en présence de
médecins légistes ouest allemand et de
deux médecins étrangers un suisse et un
belge trois avocats étaient également
présents nous reviendrons dans quelques
minutes avec bernard welker en direct de
bonnes sur le mystère qui continuent
d'entourer ces suicides qui ont eu lieu
après l'échec des terroristes ramené à
mogadiscio
l'assaut des commandos gsg9 ouest
allemand a ruiné donc tous les espoirs
des amis de bader un assaut qui a été
suivie en direct par un israélien
michaël gourdes us cet homme fils de
l'ancien directeur de l'aïe
p à tel-aviv travaille au service d
écoute de la radio et de la télévision
israélienne
il dispose pour cela d'un système
d'écouté d'enregistrement fort
perfectionner grâce à ce dispositif
mais qu'at elle gourdes us était en
liaison avec le pilote du boeing qui a
amené à mogadiscio le commando allemand
depuis le cockpit de son appareil le
pilote a suivi l'assaut il a donc décrit
en direct voici cette description
m
bien je pense que l'on viendront à 20h
donc sur cette conversation d'une
qualité de son pain très bon évidemment
mais cela est assez facile à comprendre
vous avez pu suivre dans notre édition
de 20h hier soir à l'arrivée les otages
à francfort vous avez pu suivre aussi
l'arrivée du commando anti terroriste
allemand manqué les premières images
reçues de mogadiscio en somalie les
voici
c'est la dernière journée des otages là
bas avant et après l'assaut des images
que commente pour nous éric gilbert
mogadishio république de somalie lundi 6
heures 20 du matin venant d'aden le
boeing des otages vient de se poser en
bout de piste les pirates à l'intérieur
de l'appareil vont demander une heure
plus tard une ambulance un toboggan de
toile sera déroulé à l'arrière de
l'avion
un corps éjecté sur la piste ce n'est
qu'en milieu de journée qu on apprendra
que la victime est un organe schumann 37
ans le commandant du boeing a battu
vraisemblablement parce qu'il avait
quitté l'appareil au cours de l'escale
laden et qu'il ne voulait pas redécollé
dans la tour de contrôle il n'y a
pratiquement pas de dialogue avec
l'avion en effet on reçoit toutes les
communications en direct de l'appareil à
la tour de contrôle de francfort 13h30
le négociateur spécial du gouvernement
allemand monsieur vichnievsky surnommé
le cheikh
car c'est un grand spécialiste de
l'afrique et du moyen-orient où il
compte beaucoup d'amitié il a effectué
plus de 200 voyages dans cette partie du
monde monsieur vichnievsky donc débarque
à son tour à mogadicio il est accueilli
par le président de la république de
somalie
c'est lui qui va prendre les choses en
main et qui va tester la détermination
la volonté des pirates
durant toute la journée affolement aux
environs de 17h30 en effet un des
ultimatums des pirates va expirer et on
évacue les pistes prêt à toute
éventualité
et puis un deuxième appareil va se poser
face à l'avion des otages ce deuxième
appareil un boeing 707 et celui qui
amène le groupe g s 9 la brigade
spéciale antiterroriste l'appareil va
prendre place derrière le boeing
après ce sera le black out encore
aujourd'hui on ne connaît de l'opération
que ce que l'on sait par les témoignages
assez fragmentaire des témoins le reste
est secret c'était moi les voici
il est maintenant mardi matin une heure
ils viennent d'arriver dans le hall de
l'aéroport de mogadiscio qui a été
transformé en antenne médicale des
médecins en effet sont là des médecins
italiens somaliens et allemand ils ont
monté dans le hall est aussi dans la
boutique fric taxis de l'aéroport
une véritable antenne chirurgicale mais
ils n'en auront pas besoin car il n'y a
que des blessés légers parmi les
passagers
choquée épuisé par la chaleur qui
régnait à bord de l'appareil
c'est passager récupère ce petit garçon
à 4 ans avec son père il était assis
tout à l'avant de l'avion c'est à dire
presque à l'endroit où a été abattu le
commandant et organes showman
heureusement son père a pu dissimuler la
scène aux yeux de ce petit garçon qui
n'a donc rien vu et qui heureusement
pour lui a dormi pratiquement pendant
tous les cinq jours de ce terrible
calvaire épuisait le négociateur
vichnievsky va maintenant écouter les
premières explications du copilote
les pirates étaient tous dans le cockpit
au moment de l'action c'est pour ça que
tout s'est bien déroulé la tour le savez
lille copilote
le chef du commando et et exubérant il
était très gai il rigolait il buvait de
la bière il fumait il était très
décontracté il ne voyait pas du tout ce
qui allait se passer
voici la seule survivante du groupe de
terroristes une jeune arabe une jeune
palestinienne
elle est grièvement blessée elle crie
encore victoire pour les arabes victoire
pour les arabes d'après tous les
témoignages ce sont les deux femmes
parmi les terroristes qui se sont
montrés les plus durs sur l'identité de
ces terroristes peu de précision encore
vraisemblablement ils étaient tous
arabes
le plus pénible est bien c'est que l'on
nous a attaché à nos sièges on nous
avait fait enlever nos bas et on nous
avait lié les mains liées les pieds et
on était très serrée à deux reprises les
pirates qui ont procédé un site c'est
vraiment ce qu'il y avait de plus
pénible relation tout s'est déroulé très
vite en fait on n'a rien vu on entendu
des explosions du bruit on croyait que
c'était les pirates qui étaient à
l'extérieur de l'appareil
et puis qu'est ce qu'on a fait bien on
s'est glissé on a mis nos têtes dans nos
mains c'est tout ce que l'on pouvait
faire et alors on a entendu en allemand
d instruction qui nous disait de nous
protéger alors on a compris qu'on était
libérés quand allait être libéré
nous étions très déprimée par moments à
d'autres moments nous avions espoir mais
à la fin c'est toujours des mois je
n'avais plus d'espoir le comportement du
chef du commando du chef terroriste
était tout à fait incohérent
irrationnels a certainement il était
adorable il s'occupait des malades
il s'occupait des enfants et puis
quelques minutes plus tard il se mettait
à hurler et bien sûr ces changements
agissez sur nos terres nous aussi nous
passions par des fins d'espoir et aussi
des phases de dépression
dow jones à des prix mieux dans tout le
monde d'ailleurs mettra bon dans cet
appareil
l'incohérence du discours politique
tenue par les terroristes
cet homme lui était tout près de
l'endroit où les commandes ont été
vaincus le commandant dit il est resté
cinq ou six heures dans la halle et les
terroristes passer au dessus de son
corps avec indifférence
ce n'est qu avant l'atterrissage à
mogadishu que finalement commandant a
été traîné tout au nom de l'appareil et
qu'on la plaçait dans une petit
emplacement où il y avait les masques à
oxygène et les appareillages de secours
francfort 14 heures 30 après les otages
libérés
voici la héros du jour le groupe g s9
les trente hommes qui en 2 minutes 30
en offrant au cauchemar voilà pour ces
témoignages voilà pour les dernières
pièces à conviction que nous avions à
notre disposition pour vous les
présenter dans le cadre de ce que nous
avons pu faire depuis maintenant
plusieurs jours sur cette affaire et
surtout depuis sa conclusion
sa conclusion peut-être pas tout de
suite car en ce moment je suppose
bernard welker carbone si l'euphorie de
l'après intervention est passé on en
vient maintenant aux problèmes plus
sérieux et en particulier je viens
d'apprendre par une dépêche qui vient de
chez vous que l'autopsié des corps
d'andreas baader et de goudron
naisseline pourrait bien amener quelques
discussions au niveau de ceux qui ont
participé à l'autopsié
oui l'alm déroge aujourd'hui sur le
suicide andreas baader et de ses amis
des discussions il y en a beaucoup et
dans toute la presse monsieur chili
l'avocat de good run slinky a été
retrouvé pendu à une corde électrique
haut à la fenêtre de sa cellule tient en
ce moment une conférence de presse et
voici ce qu'il nous a dit avant de
commencer cette conférence de presse
j'ai pu lui poser deux ou trois
questions
je pense que la question de savoir si
c'est un suicide ou un meurtre n'a pas
encore de réponse
le fait que race peu et bader sont morts
par balle peut faire penser à un meurtre
les cellules sans fouiller chaque jour
elles étaient les cellules et mieux
contrôler de la rfa et c'est impossible
d'imaginer et d'expliquer comment ils
ont pu se procurer des armes
j'étais hier la prison bader gisait dans
une mare de sang
2 madame spleen on ne voyait que les
gens d'après moi à baader a reçu un coup
de revolver dans la nuit la balle j'ai
tiré à bout portant l entrée dans la
tête vers le haut mais il vaut mieux
attendre les résultats de l'autopsié
nous n'avons pas encore pu parler à yang
art moeller qui a également tenté de se
suicider mais qui est hors de danger
tous les journaux s'interrogent sur ces
suicides ce matin et se demande aussi
comment bader heras peu pouvaient avoir
un revolver on pense que le ministre de
la justice du bade wurtemberg devra
démissionner les résultats de l'autopsié
ne sont donc pas encore connus comme
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure et la
nouvelle selon laquelle bader et blessé
à une blessure dans la nuque n'est pas
confirmée du tout en tout cas ce matin
les services de lutte anti terroriste
n'ont pas démobilisé après le succès de
l'opération de mogadiscio car on
s'attend selon certaines rumeurs à ce
que les personnes qui ont enlevé
monsieur schleier frappe maintenant un
grand coup pour rehausser leur prestige
car nous en parlions hier au cours de
notre édition de 13h avec heinz org et
vous même est-ce qu'on avait
l'impression maintenant après que les
choses se sont un peu décantées que l'on
risque de voir éclore une vague de
terrorisme à travers l'allemagne
fédérale après ce qui s'est passé
écoutez oui hier j'avais répondu je ne
le pensais pas et je ne pense toujours
pas mais les informations qui nous
viennent du gouvernement et des services
de sécurité font au contraire état de
rumeurs selon lesquelles les terroristes
et notamment ceux qui ont enlevé
monsieur flyers qui sont toujours dans
la nature on ne sait pas ou que cela
préparait un grand coup mais finalement
est-ce qu'il ne s'agit pas si vous
voulez d'une tendance du gouvernement à
exagérer un peu les choses justement
pour que l'on se laisse pas trop aller à
l'optimisme après la réussite de vos
dadishow peut être que c'est pour ça si
par hasard la la thèse de l'avocat
d'andreas baader étaient confirmés par
les résultats officiels de tle si vous
pensez que il y aura autour de lui avait
parlé d'une démission du ministre de la
justice du bade-würtemberg mais au-delà
de cette démission penser qu'on pourrait
assister à une tempête politique
ah oui absolument oui si vraiment il est
confirmé que bader a été exécuté est
vraiment j'insiste pour dire que pour le
moment rien ne permet de le dire mais si
cela était confirmé cela provoquerait
naturellement en allemagne une tempête
politique et un scandale épouvantable et
ce ne serait pas seulement le ministre
de la justice du bade wurtemberg qui
sauteraient mais c est bien beau bien
plus haut hier merci bernard matière
pour ces précisions certainement vous
avez l'occasion de revenir sur cette
affaire dans les traditions de 20h avec
roger gicquel cela dit voyant la suite
de l'activité michel denisot le conseil
des ministres de ce matin devait être
consacré essentiellement aux énergies
nouvelles tout de suite des détails avec
jacques noirs qui étaient les lisent
oui michel denisot avant de parler de
ces mesures concernant les énergies
nouvelles je vous indique que deux
projets de loi ont été adoptés ce matin
par le conseil des ministres le premier
prévoit la gratuité totale des actes de
justice devant les tribunaux
administratifs et civils
c'est une un projet de loi qui devrait
déposer son tour de l'assemblée
nationale dès le mois de novembre
second projet de loi il met à jour il le
réforme la législation sur la
conservation des archives c'est une
mesure qui intéresse c'est certain
surtout les historiens de l'avenir mais
il est bon de signaler que la
législation en vigueur jusqu'à présent
daté du 7 mai si d'heure en deux on le
voit elle était assez 17 dépasser cette
législation
signalons d'autre part que jean jacques
brot clair le secrétaire d'état aux
anciens combattants à a précisé que
cette année encore la journée du 11
novembre revêtira une ampleur
exceptionnelle tant en paris à paris
qu'en province
signalons aussi une communication de
monsieur black le ministre du travail
qui a dressé un premier bilan sur la
situation de l'emploi
premier bilan depuis la rentrée c'est un
bilan d'un optimisme assez modérée
monsieur black a dit qu'il y avait des
progrès mais qu'il fallait rester très
prudent et puis nous en ont donc au gros
morceau de ce conseil à savoir les
mesures sur l'utilisation des énergies
nouvelles ces énergies nouvelles c'est
d'une part l'énergie solaire et d'autre
part la géothermie c'est à dire
l'utilisation de l'eau chaude alors à ce
propos des décisions qui visent
par augmenter les crédits les
subventions pour permettre notamment la
construction de la première centrale
expérimentale à énergie solaire en
france des mesures d'incitation aussi à
l'aide de subventions pour inciter les
particuliers à utiliser cette énergie
solaire sur cela d'autres commentaires
maintenant avec michel chevalet à vous
au lycée mesures sur les énergies
nouvelles apporte semble-t-il un second
souffle à une politique qui étaient
venus jusqu'à maintenant coup par coup
michel chevalet oui en effet le but
recherché par le gouvernement c'est de
donner un second souffle précisément aux
énergies nouvelles et ça vous allez le
voir en faisant sauter un verrou un
verrou qui n'étaient pas d'ordre
psychologique parce que tout le monde
est convaincu du bien-fondé soit de
l'utilisation du solaire soit de
l'utilisation de cette eau chaude
gratuite qui vient souvent dans sous sol
mais un verrou qui est uniquement
d'ordre financier car il faut bien
reconnaître malheureusement ces énergies
nouvelles sont encore beaucoup trop cher
plus cher que l'utilisation du chauffage
classique par le fioul alors là le
gouvernement joue sur deux tableaux
le premier c'est au niveau du simple
particulier ou lorsque par exemple vous
équiperez d'un chauffage solaire
vous obtiendrez une subvention du
gouvernement et non pas une simple
déduction fiscale
cette subvention sera que le coût de
l'installation ne sera pas plus cher
qu'une installation classique par
exemple ou fioul ou au gaz
ensuite lors du dépôt d'un programme de
construction soit de logements soit deux
bâtiments publics
il devra obligatoirement figurer
l'utilisation des énergies nouvelles
ensuite le gouvernement lui va jouer au
niveau des industriels et ce bien sûr
dans le but de faire baisser les prix
à la fabrique assure par exemple une
société publique va être constituée pour
financer la mise en oeuvre de chauffage
d'immeubles par la géothermie le but
étant de passer de 12000 à 24000
logement pour le solaire le gouvernement
va lancer une commande portant sur 3000
installation de chauffage par des
chauffe eau solaires en quelque sorte
lagence pour les économies d'énergie
enfin je veux dire pour les énergies
nouvelles va se constituer en centrales
d'achat reste enfin les centrales
solaires une va être construite dans le
midi l'autre à l'échelon européen
en quelque sorte vous le voyez on quitte
le coup par coup pour passer pour
quitter ils ont l'artisanat pour
réellement entrer
maintenant dans l'industrie en politique
13e réunion des partis de la majorité ce
matin pour examiner les circonscriptions
électorales jusqu'à ce jour 220
circonscriptions sur 491 ont été passés
en revue
à caen hier soir au cours d'une réunion
organisée par l'association pour la
démocratie à lise saulnier a été
secrétaire d'état aux universités a pris
la défense de l'école libre la liberté
exige le pluralisme at elle dit en
substance de la république ne peut se
limiter à la doctrine d'un seul parti
l'école de la république ne peut
enseigner une seule doctrine l'école de
la république doit enseigner la
république
d'autres l'ont dit avant moi et bien
longtemps avant moi la république dans
sa diversité dans sa tolérance et c'est
pourquoi nous ne devons pas oublier nous
les libéraux que nous sommes les seuls à
y faut au contraire le parti qui se veut
unique commence par vouloir bien
évidemment une école unique une
structure scolaire unique et le
processus est réaliste
en réalité car en supprimant la liberté
fondamentale de l'enseignement en
formant des esprits docile à une seule
doctrine ont largué par anticipation
toutes les formes de liberté la liberté
et la qualité de l'enseignement exigent
le maintien de la diversité la qualité
de l'enseignement public exige le
maintien de l'enseignement privé le
monopole que l'on instaurerait selon le
voeu de certains dans l'enseignement
public ne pourrait qu elle produire à
terme et même à très court terme
l'intolérance en bref maintenant
révélation tardive sur la disparition de
180 kilos d'uranium aux états unis en
1966 à l'époque
dans lyndon johnson a refusé à la cia
l'autorisation d'enquêter aujourd'hui
une chaîne de télévision américaine
révèle que cet uranium aurait pris le
chemin d'israël nous n'accepterons pas
c'est le titre de l'éditorial de rené
andrieu dans l'humanité de ce matin rené
andrieu s'insurge contre les
condamnations à de lourdes peines de
prison de quatre intellectuels
tchécoslovaque dissidents jugé par le
tribunal de prague
en l'absence de tout journaliste
étranger les six otages français enlevés
à sous et rate le 1er mai 77 par le
polisario serait aux mains d'une société
du croissant rouge sahraoui
selon l' afp l'ambassadeur français
françois leduc l'aurait affirmé à la
conférence internationale de la croix
rouge qui se tient à bucarest mais cette
intervention de françois leduc vient
d'être démentie à paris au quai d'orsay
enfin suite de l'opération janus 4
marseille une troisième plonger à moins
à moins 460 mètres a été effectué ce
matin
sport football match aller des huitièmes
de finale des coupes européennes ce soir
trois équipes françaises sont en course
dont deux en coupe de l'uefa
bastia qui reçoit les anglais de
newcastle les corps sont favoris lens
qui aura la tâche plus difficile à rome
contre la lazio de rome reste l'épreuve
reine la coupe des champions
nantes qui a éliminé le duc la de prague
au premier tour affronte ce soir
l'atlético de madrid après l'élimination
de saint-etienne l'espoir du football
français c'est le fc nantes
après les verts les jaunes bernard
gibout effectivement michel denisot et
c'est avec deux buts d'avancé que les
nantais souhaiterais aborder le match
retour pour s'imposer à l'aller ce soir
le fc nantes bénéficie de trois
avantages celui du terrain bien sûr
l'absence de l'homme fort de l'atletico
le brésilien luiz pereira suspendu pour
un match
et puis aussi la genèse d'une équipe
nantaise rassuré par ses récentes
performances
cette jeunesse insouciante et combative
de l'équipe de nantes sera l'atout
principal pour faire face à l'expérience
de l'atlético de madrid qui il y a trois
ans eût déjà finaliste de la coupe
d'europe des clubs champions en
l'absence d' amis suspendu et de shannon
toujours indisponible pour des raisons
de santé
jean vincent a retenu baronne kelly
pécout et lacombe
dans sa ligne d'attaqué
connais la façon de jouer de l'atlético
de madrid c'est défense de faire
c'est-à-dire superbe et ont alors
entonné en cours des indispositions de
pereira ils vont encore resserrer
davantage le regarder ça sera très
difficile pour percer leur défense j'ai
l'impression que en plus ils seront très
dangereux dans les contres avec ayala en
particulier qui va faire sa rentrée qui
est un peu le style rocheteau c'est à
dire c'est le gars qui est capable
d'éliminer leurs adversaires d'aller
seul au but mais a aussi robben canaux
qui affectionne en particulier les
grands espaces libres
hélas je crains justement ces contres
dangereux de leur part pensez vous
toujours prendre deux buts d'avancé
demain soir bien sûr c'est qu'il faut
espérer c'est l'objectif et puis on sait
très bien que au match retour
ils vont certainement à voir leur équipe
au complet et à ce moment là ça sera
encore plus difficile pour nous y avant
d'en venir à la météo à noter que
plusieurs rivières ont débordé dans les
pyrénées orientales et l'aude à la suite
des pluies diluviennes de ces derniers
jours causant d'importants dégâts dans
la nuit de mardi à mercredi des trombes
d'eau se sont abattues sur les
contreforts pyrénéens dans les rouleaux
roussillon et les corbières entraînant
des inondations en plusieurs points du
département
la météo pour cet après-midi pluies
orageuses parfois importantes qui
affecteront toujours le roussillon et
aussi le sud du massif central tandis
que près de l'atlantique les pluies
seront éparses
ailleurs le temps sera assez beau malgré
quelques passages nuageux
demain les plus orageuses s'étendront à
toutes les régions méditerranéennes
tandis que quelques pluies éparses
persisteront de la manche occidentale
aux pyrénées ailleurs après les
brouillards matinaux le temps sera
nuageux avec des éclaircies
il ya encore dans notre édition de 13h à
léger incident technique nous a empêchés
de diffuser comme nous le souhaitions
lors de notre passage au conseil
économique et social un sujet réalisé
sur le rôle de ce conseil par alain bel
air alors pour nous rattraper et bien
voici ce sujet puisque les débits très
nombreux à nous le réclament et dès la
fin de l'émission
le conseil économique et social un
immeuble d'auguste perret du plus pur
style de l'entre-deux-guerres 200
conseillers économiques et sociaux s'y
retrouvent toutes les semaines
200 conseillers désignés aux trois
quarts par les syndicats les
organisations professionnelles le
dernier quart étant constitué de
personnalités choisies par le
gouvernement en raison de leurs
compétences
un hémicycle comme au palais bourbon
mais ici pas de gauche ni de droite
quinze groupes ceux des entreprises
privées des classes moyennes de
l'agriculture de l'artisanat de chacune
des centrales syndicales cgt cfdt fo cgc
et c'est le président est élu avec le
jus roe de 14 membres pour deux ans et
demi la dernière élection sur ces images
s'est déroulée en aimant jean-josé
clément philippe j'ai toujours souhaité
qu' une assemblée comme la nôtre ici
s'instaure un dialogue en profondeur sur
les grands problèmes de notre vie
économique et sociale
le conseil est une assemblée
consultative sa vocation élaborer des
rapports à la demande du gouvernement ou
de sa propre initiative
les deux derniers ont été adoptés la
semaine dernière deux sujets d'actualité
l'avenir de la viticulture française
présentée par un agriculteur rivaux gars
et l'emploi des jeunes présenté par le
représentant de la fen robert chez rano
des études qui avant d'être discuté en
séance plénière sont longuement préparés
en commission il y en a deux
et puis deux fois par an le conseil
dresse le bilan de santé de l'économie
en présence des principaux intéressés
ici raymond barre des entreprises pour
moi monsieur rolland ne sont pas des
entités qu'il faut détruire
sont au contraire les unités économiques
qui contribuent à la production à
l'emploi l'investissement et à
l'exportation
valéry giscard d'estaing venait
régulièrement en tant que ministre des
finances la dernière fois c'était le 18
décembre 73 alors qu'éclatait la crise
de l'énergie
hier quatre ans plus tard le président
de la république affirmé c'est une
nouvelle étape que nous vivons un
changement du monde voit donc pour
l'essentiel de l'actualité en ce début
d'après midi je ne sais pas si une
information importante
ahmed communiqué avant la bourse je
regarde rapidement la thèse du suicide
des membres de la ffr mise en doute par
l'avocat aïn el hamman bien rien de
particulier pour l'instant c'est une
dépêche concernant bien entendu la
sphère dont nous parlions rigueur n'en
veulent qu'à et qui commence à susciter
quelques remous en allemagne fédérale
autour de cette affaire du suicide
d'andreas baader suicide entre
guillemets et la certain nombre de ses
camarades participants la fraction armée
rouge je pense que roger rigall ce soit
pour être vus donner de plus amples
détails
si honda résultats communiqués de
l'hôtel sites définis sur la vie est
bien à la bourse pour détendre
oui et bien l'ambiance se réchauffe
chaque jour davantage à la bourse ou osi
les valeurs françaises accomplissent en
effet une nouvelle étape de hausse
aujourd'hui dans un marché d'ailleurs un
petit peu plus étoffé que ces jours
derniers les indicateurs sont à cet
égard révélateur loyer + 1 1,36 % de
hausse
et ça s'améliore derrière le calme qui
semble se confirmer sur le marché des
changes le dollar baisse encore un peu
les avis du franc alors que la france
eut que le franc suisse vaut désormais
plus cher que le mark allemand explique
en grande partie ce renouveau des
valeurs françaises c'est en effet pour
une grande part aux achats étrangers
qu'on doit l'amélioration enregistrée
depuis deux jours les investisseurs
étrangers ayant notamment été
impressionné par le redressement de
notre balance commerciale
la baisse d'un huitième de points du
loyer
l'argent devait ce que permet la bonne
tenue du franc vis-à-vis du dollar
encouragent par ailleurs les
investisseurs institutionnels français à
convertir un peu de leur argent liquide
en valeurs françaises ce qui explique
les mots ce que vous voyez aujourd'hui
devant et cela d'autant plus payant
souvent pris trop de précautions en
vendant sous conditions une partie de
leur portefeuille
c'est un investisseur institutionnel
sont obligés en ce jour de réponse des
primes jour où l'on fait le bilan des
engagements conditionnels ils sont un
peu obligé de se racheter
puisque tout ou presque a monté depuis
trois mois mais la clientèle française
hélas fait encore défaut et c'est
pourquoi le syndic de la compagnie les
agents de change monsieur sy flornoy a
décidé de demander aux partis politiques
à tous les partis politiques de dire ce
qu'il pense et ce qu'ils veulent faire
du marché financier français
pourquoi les agents de change sortie
aujourd'hui de leur réserve
traditionnelle parce que a répondu tout
à l'heure monsieur sy flornoy parce que
la bourse jouent un rôle et continuera
dangereux rien quel que soit le résultat
des élections et parce qu'il faut bien
que quelqu'un parle au nom des
épargnants qui s'intéressent à la bourse
et musc flornoy on entend poser au cours
d'un forum qui se tiendra début décembre
trois questions nationaliser demain
peut-être mais comment et jusqu'où
peut-on vraiment faire de paris une
place financière internationale avec
quel capitaux entendons demain faire
l'investissement
en attendant la bourse aujourd'hui se
porte bien le marché de l'or est
également bien orienté ce matin à
londres l'once d'or fin est monté à 161
dollars 55 la barre ou le voyait à
gagner 80 francs le kilo 75 francs
tandis que napoléon perdait 50 centimes
les valeurs étrangères sont moins bien
orientées à wall street
boudu toujours les valeurs allemandes
qui avait beaucoup monté hier
rob est ce un petit peu aujourd'hui et
seuls les mines d'or encore
qu'irrégulière varie peu aimée sont
quand même un petit peu en hausse il ya
toujours beaucoup de spéculation sur
istres en naturellement qui n'est pas
encore coté l'emprunt quatre ennemis
pour 173 à 657 francs despair 80
centimes puis la casse national de
l'énergie a perdu 1 franc mais l'emprunt
7% 73 à lui gagné 80 centimes à 252,4
une très bonne séance donc aujourd'hui
ici la bourse de paris à vous hymne aux
merci on est en droit il me reste à vous
souhaiter à tout
san excellente après-midi surtout à vous
les jeunes à l écoute de tf1 rendez vous
demain 13h ici même